good morning from South Africa guys
we're going to go to the beautiful
Orange River it's a 7 hours drive and
we're going to do some fishing we're
going to do some hunting we're going to
do men's stuff not that women can't do
it but it's going to be a men's trip
jock is going to go with us as well
we're going to get Donnie there but
first we need to get everything
here in there in South Africa we call it
a baky you guys call it a truck but
let's get to
it come
moner
thank you thank
you bye let's
go so there are a lot of Road stops here
in South Africa and now we just sit and
wait but me and Jo we've got some potos
South Africa we call this potos and this
is amazing we've got some pancakes here
some food for the road and then some of
these meatballs let me tell you this is
the best thing you can buy if you're in
South Africa on the
[Music]
road
woo
we finally arrived here at Salon kums me
and jock we are here but Donnie our
friend BS he already beat us to it and
um as you can see we busy with the
tackle here because it's very windy look
at the beautiful River so we're not
going to fish today might be a little
bit too late with this wind tomorrow
we're definitely going to give it a shot
right guys it is late so I'm going to
sleep tomorrow we're going to go and do
some fishing it's a beautiful unit that
they have here at salmon kst I'm going
to leave all the details for you guys in
the video description if you want to
come here have a sleepover and catch
some fish which we will do in the
morning so I'll see you in the
[Music]
morning good morning guys what a
beautiful morning it is here at the
Orange River I mean just look at
it it's a bit windy but it's still okay
I got my coffee and uh going to do some
Bible studying with the guys there they
are so we'll see you guys a little bit
[Music]
later w we just had an amazing time just
in God's word and uh we pray together
and you know it feels so good starting
the day like this with God but there's a
small gym here and because this is a
men's game getaway a men's weekend we're
going to work out together as well so
let's get to
it I'm ready to work out but I forgot my
shoes jock says he's got some shoes for
me as
well thank you Donnie you got some shoes
as well y we came prepared you guys
prepared yeah and I took care of my bare
feet man these units look good so who
sleeps in this one that's
me wow it's quite nice huh yeah and then
if you just walk
out you have the river so you guys ready
to work
out
ready wow this is a nice spot
huh y look at
this oh nice looks like everything we
need huh this is so beautiful I think we
should just come and live here just come
and stay here
I'm older you I'm I'm getting gray now
so be gentle
jock oh I'm getting old but not
cold wouldn't say it a lot but Jo these
guns it doesn't he doesn't have a permit
for
those in trouble yeah oh well
done huh let me see those
guns they definitely got big coughs look
at those yo monsters you've got the best
beast see a little bit no can't see it
put them down put them down let me see
wait wait wait wait
yes
y but I've got the best ones look at
these
monsters we can't almost see them huh
there's no cares there yeah
nothing
but those those are the coughs God gave
me so I'm
content we're busy working out jockey is
doing his last set over there he's done
but while we were working out we saw
some fish jump here and they're going
crazy we're going to quickly go we're
going to do a few costs and see if we
can get a fish or two ready Jo we've got
the roads we' got everything sure the
wind is still not in our favor but uh
yeah we're ready to
[Music]
go this is quite nice because it's not
easy to get to the
location and that's part of the
fun
I'm not sure if we can go through this
area if it's shallow enough but let's
have a
lookoo okay we made it but it's a little
bit
deep I think we should move a little bit
further
on wow it's beautiful here I think this
is the spot let's see what we can catch
my granddad had a farm and on the
farm we fished a lot on the Orange River
so this is special so to start this off
I'm going to fish the way my granddad
fished now the fish we're going to catch
here they are indigenous to South Africa
the amazing yellow fish now these fish
man they are amazing when they bite they
take off like a Ferrari and so it's one
of the the best fish that you can catch
here in South Africa and that's what I'm
going to show you today there are two
types small mouth and large mouth now
the large mouth are more rare but
they're more hunters and they've got big
mouths but if you do catch them they can
go over 10 kilos so that's what we hope
to catch so let me show you quickly here
what I've
done so the
Sinker it's going to be very
easy just put it in like that you bring
it around you bring it in and done then
you do the exact same thing with the two
hooks and then I'm going to try to catch
the yellowfish and the method that we
call Poco here in South Africa I'm going
to take some dough some cake flour and
I'm going to add some special unique
well let me just show you what I'm going
to do but first let me add the hooks so
these are the size hooks that you want
to use it's not big just the right size
for these
fish let me just hold this on here don't
do this at
home and you just go around and pull it
through there you go that's the one I'm
going to add another one
here there we go
around and through there we
go quick and easy now we need to make
the
dough so I got some cake flour here and
all I'm going to do is I'm going to use
the water of the river and I'm just
going to make a dough you can see Donnie
is already there fishing and he's using
lure so you can catch these fish with
lures fly fishing or Pap as we call it
in South
Africa
all right so I added the water now you
got to just do the
mixture and make some nice dough we hope
that Donnie is going to catch a fish
over here Donnie any bites little
nibbles little
nibbles so I brought some secret stuff
with me and we call them certain dips
here in South Africa it's the same
method that people use to catch carp
here as well but let me show
you and this is a dip that we're going
to use it's smells interesting some of
it smells like garlic some of it smells
like cinnamon you get different types
but these fish love it and here on the
Orange River they like cinnamon so I've
got cinnamon one and I've got a few
other things as well and I'm going to
show you how you put this on the hook
with these uh dips to present the bait
and then see if we can catch something I
think we are close I think this is
it this is it I'm just going to wash my
hands quickly but this is what you want
this is the consistency and uh we only
use a little bit at a time so all you
need is a small piece like this and then
what you do is you just roll it a little
bit like a snake almost and then once
you have that you take the
hook there we go now next up we're going
to take the two dips never take the same
dip because we need to figure out which
one the fish like so first we're going
to do the cinema on the top hook and
we're going to do the sniper concent tra
on the bottom one let's do
that my grandma as well she love to fish
going to make them proud um this is not
my favorite method I like to catch with
lures like Donnie and we're going to
give that a shot a little bit later on
as well but there we go in you go done
we forgot to to bring a few things to
put the the rods on so we're just going
to have to take some branches here and
do what we can just make a
plan
let's cast it in and see what we can
catch now I'm trying my my granddad's
method and I'm using nik's Rod you can
see it's pink and you put this on we
call it a polic man here in South Africa
and so when the F bites you will see it
move I'm not going to cost it in really
far all
right here you go all we got to do is
just look at that little guy when he
starts to move up then we know it's
time the angle oh it's already
biting so Daniel's on CH nothing
yet what's happening what's happening
what's Happ on but I don't know what it
is and he going to Jo's line over there
a it's quite it's quite a nice fish but
it plays a little bit strange not like a
yellow
fish but you can see it oh it's taking
some
line it's an old Rod it's A's Rod as
well but I think we're going to move
away from Jo so we don't bother him here
with his
life hey go
yeah oh no it's a mut
fish taking a line
again man this is
awesome I
it no it's
okay I'm just too hasty but maybe I
should just wait and play a little bit
he's very thin line
so got to be
careful oh got it this is quite a nice
mud fish Y in Africans we say mfish but
let me take it out quickly
here all right beautiful fish and that's
why we call it a mud fish look at the
mouth there at the
bottom it's quite
strange it's very different from the the
yellow fish but uh it's a nice fish and
they don't get too big this is probably
the the biggest size that they do get
around 2 kg but still beautiful
fish so let's go put it back so when
it's ready he will go I don't want to
push him don't want him to
die come on buddy let's go thank you
there is he
goes ha
nice so the orange river is the longest
river here in South Africa it is a
beautiful
River fish on for
jock huh jock yeah hopefully this is the
first yellow fish how big is it
jock I think 20
kilos now it's a little bit difficult
there in know with those reads there
yeah Donnie do you want to net it for
him unless it's a very small one which
it probably is small let's see it's
already
here this can be the first yellow it is
it is the first yellow watch out watch
out watch out ooh Donnie you got to be
careful there it's on the oh man are you
in a
hole and the fish is still there
guys oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
no focus focus the fish is still
there we are looking like amateurs right
right
now all right is it's closing in there
we
go here we go here we
go and
nice
Jo first yellow yellow first
B Rangers also looking for oh yeah
one that's Tom com's hunting dog
looking for some
fish I'm still stuck is still stuck I
mean look at
that this
River oh no you lost your shoe I lost
Sho it's in the
[Laughter]
hole oh no all right jocky still there
let's go check out the fish no it's not
food it's not food we're not going to
give it to
you okay wow wow Jo wow
wow it's a nice size too yeah it's
beautiful let's put it
back the dog's name is Ranger and Ranger
just wants to to eat this this yellow
fish
uh let me help
you he's going to eat it
come uhuh move it move it yeah
Ranger Ranger
uhuh hold
done
yo my dad is a hunting
dog the wind is picking up here guys so
we're going to go back and uh we're
going to try this again another
day Ranger still looking for the fish
good
morning man I'm still sleepy it is still
dark out of here but
today is the big fishing day
so I'm going to get some
coffee meet up with the guys and then
we're going to do some
fishing
hey can I also have some coffee Good
morning
Tony early morning here that sounds and
smells good that's how we start a day
M got the coffee the most important
thing and and then I got these whole
grain breakfast biscuits that we're
going to take along I think they should
go down nicely with the coffee let's go
cheers so we get the fishing stuff
where's Jo so we going to wake him up
that might be a good idea let's see
where he is so the wind qued down which
is perfect but it bothers me still a
little bit that it's this cold I mean
the the yellowfish they like warm
weather and we had a bit of a cold front
so it might influence the the biting
we'll see
he's still sleeping I think so as
well
Jo nothing is
happening
Jo
hello Jo
he's still
sleeping we got to go
fishing oh I know no man the reflection
was too much he couldn't see that great
but H he was still
sleeping we older guys we're ready but
the Young Generation these days all
right we on the way we can't wait for J
We're carrying everything ourselves the
old man older
man but it is a
beautiful beautiful beautiful
morning plan of action where do you
think we should go this time we should
go down this way to the right yeah yeah
I think that looks under the trees
mhm wow this is a beautiful spot huh
yeah just looks a little bit shallow but
we'll see wow this location looks
perfect for today the wind is
calm and the location oh we can make a a
fire here and it is cold oh they've got
some wood here as well
Donnie
nice oh this is a beautiful
spot huh cool for a proper South African
yeah I think so too let's do some
fishing 2,000 years later jockey is
finally here
good morning jock are you awake now good
evening finally the fishing is done
we're actually going home
[Laughter]
now let's get the rods in today I'm
going to stick with the method that my
Grandad used my grandma we call this a
Buddha strop so let's see what we can
catch
I'm going to try the
lure as well it's a little bit cold not
sure if I'm going to get anything but if
you don't try you'll never
know now that was
bite it's just too
[Music]
cold
Don gave a nice um pull on your Rod as
well they're just like nibbling yeah
they're not really biting biting but you
can see it I mean look at this one oh
there we get some more action we just
needed to to take it mhm
H All For You just
run it's a bit more shallow here than I
than I would have liked it to
be I think I'm going to go enjoy my
coffee a little bit more wait for
these they nibbling and nibbling
but not really taking it we might need
to make a b plan here I tried with the
uh lure but it's it's too
shallow yeah this SP is a bit too quiet
it might be the weather as well but I
think I'm I'm GNA change tactics here I
think I'm going to move from
here to there I can see some fish just
jumping around we are slowly getting
hungry so we might go for breakfast soon
but we don't want to go for breakfast
before we got a fish feel like we don't
deserve
it so that one is far
in oh time for these cookies Donnie how
are they Del good jock is busy getting
his Rod ready but these
are quite amazing healthy as
well no sugar this is what they look
like but I just need my coffee with this
there we
go
[Music]
I still think it's too shallow here and
I I can see the fish jumping and playing
all the way over there so I'm going to
try with the The Lure just to give it a
shot maybe it's a little bit deeper
there
my legs are freezing but uh I gave him
my all and uh it's not going to work
here the fish are not biting at the
moment it's too cold and it's too
shallow here where we are so I think
we're going to go have some breakfast
because I'm hungry and then uh after
that we're going to try to catch bass
there's a bass Dam here and uh hopefully
they will be more willing to take our
lures than the
[Music]
yellowfish wow this is nice good morning
good
morning oh more coffee
o o orange juice yogurt all right we got
some bread some
cheese let's have a
look bacon hash brownies some beans
W so good what's in here ooh eggs ooh
this is what we call Kel ppup in South
Africa and then we got some
sauce oh look at this man early in the
morning oh I feels so good this is how
you started morning huh are you still
cold still cold oh my clothes are still
wet my shoes man it's cold on
mhm oh
what do you got there jock too much food
oo Don all the yummy goodness you guys
are hungry huh
uhhuh thank you Lord Jesus for the food
amen surprise
bre you guys ready let's go see if we
can catch them
bass so this gate is now working and
Donnie and Jo they opening this gate but
the gate is falling
apart there we go it's a beautiful Farm
there's game here as well a lot of deer
which I will show you a little bit later
today is a fishing day but tomorrow
we're going
hunting it's a beautiful little
Dam
sun is coming
out still a little bit chilly but you
can feel the
sun now of these baths I'm going to try
this soft plastic there's a lot of
places where you can get snagged a lot
of grass a lot of things with normal
lure so I'm trying the soft plastic and
I'm putting the hook right in there so
that uh we can just reel it in and uh it
doesn't get stuck on anything there's a
lot of other soft PL Plastics that you
could use so we brought quite a few here
but uh this one is the best option you
can see DA's already there and jock is
somewhere
here oh he's right there behind that
tree the best thing with bass is
obstacles I'm going to try here and then
I'm just going to work work my way
around and see what we can
get
Jo got a a nice one
first nice Jo it's bleeding a lot oh man
let's uh yeah let's get it back let's
just change location and see what we can
get yeah this is a nice
spot hey Donnie's got one there let's go
check it out I want to go and uh see if
I can find another location here while
walking seeing if I can spot some of
them while I walked to Donnie just to
check out the fish that he just caught
he said he got a small
bass oh it's nice and deep here nice
structure but so much grass
there nice yeah got one yeah man what um
lure did you use uh one of those little
jeny ones oh really it didn't even chase
mine oh I'm trying to follow it with the
camera nice yeah I nibbled nibbled and
then he he took it took
it oh got it fish
on
yes there we go guys this is this a
small one but let's see if we can catch
its grandfather throwback
all right there it goes let's get
another one see the thing is with basses
you need to go and find them and hunt
them which is why I love catching
bass but it's also just nice you know
just to take in the moment and the
surroundings around you I mean it is
quiet no
traffic not music not a lot of people
nothing just you and
nature we need this
thank you Lord
Jesus we have to have life and enjoy
life to the full you can see it right
there you see it moving
day so I think there are two there's one
day one day as well not sure if you will
be able to see it with the
camera but I'm going to Chuck my lure
there and see if I can get
it oh got
it fish
[Music]
on I lost it it went into all the grass
and I just I just lost
it I'm trying to see if I can spot some
of
them oh there they are there they are
see that big rock just to the right of
that rock there's one
there right
there oh he
on man that's so much
fun oh oh lost
it oh man I lost
it I think I'm going to change
tactics going to try a map spinner I'll
just have to take off the grass and
stuff every now and
then all right let's give it a
go
fish
on very small one but at least they're
chasing
now oh it just got off oh
man it just got off but at least it's
working the map spinner they're chasing
it so they want some bling it's is
difficult because there's so so much
grass here so you got to throw in
between the Deep
areas hey you got it yeah just when I
was moving away woo you did see it it
was hiding there in the grass yeah was
below
yeah nice Donnie yeah man just when I
walked away ah oh ye of little faith
yeah I'm sorry my friend
these little ones they need to go call
Mommy and Daddy right there you go
little guy oh and he's
gone man this is a lot of
fun oh there's one right over there oh
Donnie's got another
one whoo he's got a big one woo this is
a bit bigger one my goodness not too bad
and did you have the GoPro on probably
not I I did
not that's all right this enjoy the
moment well let me get a photo you on
showing you guys how it's done
yeah now this is the trick people pull
you know now it's a smaller fish now
bring it to the camera oh now I got a
big
fish secet one two oh this is a nice one
go and get bigger buddy yeah
woo there he goes like a rocket yeah
well
done oh there's the little one you can
see it right
there all right through it far in so
let's see when we get
it fast the little
guy oh I run away oh there oh another
one crey took it
wow oh went behind the tree that's not
good that's not good come back come back
buddy oh not in the tree there we go and
it's out and it's out and it's out
oh yeah fish
on there we
go all right that was a lot of fun
whenever you're fishing you do need
pliers like this it makes this so much
easier
there we go all right let's put this guy
back in the water when you do handle bad
you need to take it here on the the
bottom Li and just support it a little
bit here at the bottom let's put the
little guy back all right and there you
go oh so much fun you see
it right there right there right there I
looking the wrong way come on come on
yes yes yes yes oh got it
nice
buddy oh man that's so much fun if you
see them it really is huh not bad yeah
it's a it's a little guy it's not as big
as yours that's not too bad at
all it's so much fun when you can see
them huh and you see that
chase there we go one two
three that's great nice thank you let's
put him
back all right
gone you got to catch it fast I've only
got
15% on the battery no
pressure it's there it's underneath him
he's going to take it oh he's got it oh
you did you lose oh oh
man it was too
loose oh no Donnie goodness always check
your
gear right oh jockey is
on who look at that
one oh you lost it yeah it's off oh I
saw a
jump I got this oh man I think the
morning fishing is done we're a little
bit tired and um we're going to go back
we're going to just check out another
fishing spot for the yellow fish quickly
then we're going to take it easy and
then uh we're only going to do a little
bit of fishing later on and a
barbecue that should be quite nice are
on the campfire Jo and Donnie they're
already here ready to go and Donnie got
the biggest fish again you like the
biggest fish catching the biggest fish H
I'm just showing you guys how it's
done Jo I didn't see with many fish
today only one for the day oh man but
it's it's not my day
a
I think this looks like a nice
spot oh yeah some nice Rapids over here
oh
nice maybe we should get something to
eat get the fire while the fire is going
and see if we can catch anything and
then we eat something yeah sounds good
it is a beautiful
spot
sure
cool while the fire is doing its thing I
think we're going to see if we can catch
anything I'm not giving up on this s
lure so I'm going to give it a try Don
what are you going to do try a little
Krabby you going to try Krabby yeah bro
nice it should work in these Rapids jock
you uh also also crab crab okay all
right com give this a go crab might be
really good I also brought the fly rod
just in case if the water's too shallow
then I'm going to do the fly
rod these rocks are so slippery so I got
to be so
careful
man don't want to fall here Jo and
Donnie they're catching over there but
man
this here is too shallow so I'm trying
to get into some deeper water so right
over here this is a nice spot here for
fly fishing it's getting a little bit
deeper so I'm going to Coss in there
reel it in see what we
get ah no bites I'm going to move over
there
all right this is a more quiet place
let's see if we get anything
[Music]
here no bites guys nothing yet this is
unbelievable
guys the Sun is setting very fast got
only a few hours
so I'm going to go back I'm going to try
fly fishing let's see if that
[Music]
works I finally found some deeper water
and there are a lot of fish jumping here
the only problem is the Sun is setting
and I got to go back and make some food
and I'm actually far away so now that I
know about this location next time I'm
going to come
here the fire looks good Jo what do you
say we start the barbecue sounds good
let's do
[Music]
it
we have good food we're going to eat
good we have fet lamb sausage garlic
bread more lamb
choies look at that
meat going on the
fire this time of the day is the most
beautiful you see the sun
setting you hear the water in the
background and the
birds so beautiful one of my
favorite lamb sausages where's jock jock
loves this as well jock what do you
think about these guys nice it's a
little bit hot but we can probably put
them on right because the Sun is going
to catch us
yes do you want to put those on yes I'll
put them on
nice and then the lamb as well going on
guys how about this each guy makes his
own so we're going to divide this into
three thank you Moroccan harisa ooh this
is so good for lamb spicy now you guys
like
spicy so for the fillet just going to
take some
thyme some garlic for you
guys already at
it day also take there we go
Jo Flame Grill there we go just tastes
better
yeah it's just too hot so no fish but at
least we can we can have some meat bread
there something on the table at least
yeah it's going to be broadest do you
want one I just J do you want one yes
please
[Music]
oh this guy is
ready
M guys I think I'm going to pray for us
then we can eat yeah yeah yeah that
sounds good father thank you so much for
the food and it's amazing day we love
you we praise you amen amen
[Music]
woo
man that
sun these are so
good oh my goodness she have good
[Music]
taste it's been an amazing day so far
awesome sunset with good friends there's
going to be another day where where I'm
going to come back and I'm going to
catch these yellowfish we're back at the
lodge now and we're going to do Bible
study together because this is a men's
weekend of the DM team and just for some
of you who do not know the team this is
Donnie he's a team manager he's doing
marketing he's doing editing he's doing
almost
everything and then this is J he's the
head video editor so all the awesome
videos you see that's mostly jock and da
as well and uh reason we took this break
is just because we're overworked and we
took this time to come just do some
fishing do some hunting just be in
nature and spend time with God in his
word and to
[Music]
pray finally we're back jock and I here
at the Orange River and today we're not
leaving until we catch yellowfish and
the conditions are really good there
hasn't been a cold front the weather is
kind of perfect so I think today is the
day
so we've been walking around the river
and we don't see the yellowfish in the
Rapids so I think it's just before
spawning
season and so we should find them in a
bit more calm
water
oh yeah this is
it so we've seen some of the fish here
in the water and it's awesome because it
means that if we stay here and do a bit
of Pap my uh grandparents style then
we'll definitely get something so Jo
said that he'll stay here and do that
and I'm going to try the fly
rod
[Music]
hello swimming right there there was
another one moving there but you can see
them right
there
so let's see if I can get
them
he
dog's got
one they don't want to take the fly but
huh right in front of
you first one for the
day nice well done
nice first one for the
day
know it's so beautiful
here
chill so beautiful when you can see the
fish you can see there's something
swimming right here but this is looking
more like a a barber as we call
it it's another one right
there
thank you so much for this beautiful day
God just look at your
creation
sure woohoo got on got it got it nice oh
it's a
beast
wo oh man this is
funo this is what fly fishing is all
about man look at him
go and there he goes the prince after
Orange River
woo oh man this is so much
fun
they're so strong because of these
currents and so it pulls my rod a lot
come on
buddy
wo full of energy he does not want to
come
in I don't have my Nate with me so this
is going to be a challenge I think I'm
going to bring him to the
right
I'm just going to make him a little bit
[Laughter]
tired
woo and this is why we come
here what a beautiful
fish
sure
they're so strong because of these
currents and
uh
man they like small
Ferraris come on buddy it's time to come
in
NOP okay all right all right all right
all right all right all
right all right here we
go all
right oh oh what a beauty here we go
guys what a beautiful beautiful fish
they're made for these currents they
just super fast and they're indigenous
to South Africa and one of my most
favorite fish to catch but uh let's put
this guy
back
so I left Jed a little bit alone just to
go on an adventure and just to
go and be alone in nature and uh got a
nice yellow but I'm returning to J just
to see how he's
[Music]
doing
definitely the biggest one of C
yeah so got a big one yeah no it's going
good this side biggest fish I've got in
the river so really yeah so I'm happy so
was a PB personal best definitely yeah
man that was a was a beautiful fish sure
and gave me a fight also okay that's
awesome I also got one but maybe not as
big as
yours
nice listen to those sounds of the birds
flying
wow
now fly fishing you can see what insects
there are in the season so if you take a
rock like this turn it around and see
what we have then uh oh this been a bit
[Applause]
big you can see
here there some
worms Oh there there are many here so
jock has been catching with dough but uh
I think later on we're going to come and
get some of these earthworms and see
what we can get oh look at
this there a bottle this is a container
that we can use to put the earthworms in
so I came back to get jock because we're
changing tactics jock says it's a little
bit quiet here yep and as you can see
it's very shallow but we're going to go
to those deep Waters I saw a few days
ago and then we're going to see if we
can get some big fish with the earth
worms but first jock we need to go and
get the earthw worms you ready out of
the sun I can
see CH looks like a
ninja so I'm going to use this as a
container for our
earthworms first rule never forget your
knife so we got it let's go jock so the
first thing we we need is just a little
bit of
sand there we go and take out the
water now let's see if we can get some
some earthw worms they're quite along
look at it oo so skinny there we go this
is a nice one joke yeah o
hello there's a
[Music]
here o
there's a lot of edge up look at those
they and
they we're just going to get a few more
and then we're going to go fishing we're
here at the new spot the water is deeper
and uh we're busy with the rods jock is
busy putting in the worm on so we're
going to put a worm on the bottom one
and we're going to put a dough on the
top one and then we going to see what we
going to
get
yours yours your
yes this is so much
fun I just threw it in and it just took
it
yeah yo yo there was just another fish
going there
now this is a
fighter it's a yellow
fish he's not even so Big Woo Jo you're
on as well
let's get this one in
first come on buddy come
on oh here we
go earth
worms just look at this beautiful
Guy this is so much
fun let's put him
back
listen to the
sound it's a
monster with Nikita's
Rod now it's a little bit quiet
again oh
man also have something on oh you have
something as well Jo
this one is a
beast
yeah yes this one is he just took a lot
of
line he doesn't want to come in come
on the line is not strong
so it's so much fun Jo yep my
goodness and he's got some weight on
him
[Music]
yo he took so much line I'm visy with
him now for what 5 minutes yeah it's a
busy one look at that
Ro this is a lot of
fun this guy just wants to take
line if this fish is going to be a
catfish I'm not going to be so happy but
if it is a yellow fish it's a monster
it's really big and this line is
not not really strong very thin
line J this is a monster yep I haven't
caught a fish like this in a long time
he's strong and the current is a bit
strong as well so the idea would be to
get him here in the more calm
water ah he's taking a line again how
long have we been playing now 10
minutes it's around 10 minutes and it's
still going strong
yeah
yo this is a big fish thank you Lord
Jesus this is so much fun oh no sign of
weakness
yet I will come here again and again and
again if you guys want to come to this
place I'll add all the details in the
video description for you it's an
amazing place the people are amazing
it's beautiful there's Wildlife there's
fishing oh man if you need some nature
then just come here and if you want
monster fish then come here as well
woo all right I'm gaining I'm gaining a
little bit grind
now there it goes
again doesn't want to come jog 15
minutes now yep probably yeah it's been
a while yeah do I think I've got Jo
line all right show us who you
are ah it's running again that was close
that was close oh he's going
again I think this might be a
catfish yeah just the way he's
playing this Thin Line
catfish I
think think catfish
oh oh it's a
catfish he's too big for the for the net
for the Nets so I have to get him to the
side I was so hoping it was a yellow
fish is taking but it's it's a lot of
fun though oh Jo I forgot to mention
this is a a catch and cook ah so you'll
need to eat cat catfish with me not
eating catfish
it's a bit too slimy for my
life yo he
massive all right here we go here we go
here we go come on
buddy in the Orange River they can get
very very big this one is not even one
of the biggest they can get over 40
kilog here um but you see this is a nice
nice nice nice catfish there we go there
we go there we go look at that
guy so
heavy but he put up a good fight so so
let's put him back all right boy here we
go all right get
some there he
goes
woo that was fun nice well
done thank
you now it's my turn oh man that was so
good yeah now it's Jock's turn I'm going
to take a
break it's heating up the sun is
extremely hot now you can see we forgot
um sunscreen so Jo put some mud on his
legs just to protect him and he's
working Jo
[Music]
yeah both rods are biting but I'm just
so
tired I'm going to let it do its thing
and I'm going to have some
snacks these jalapeno pretzels are the
[Music]
best
guys this is just too much fun every
time we cast in they start biting and um
there was a big one that took mine my
rod got stuck the line broke Jo just had
a nice one as well that he missed and
now we just costed it in
again
fish
on another fish is on this is the orange
d a mudfish Mish
yeah there we
go beautiful mudfish man we're catching
all the species today we just need cop
now and the cop here in the Orange River
they put up a really good fight but uh
it's time to let this guy
go when all the conditions are right and
you're at the right spot and you've got
the right bait everything just works
fish on with a fly
rod so awesome to fight this fish with a
fly rod is just on another level
so J I'm going to bring it to you and
then you you net it if that's okay
yeah I can see
it
and it's a mudfish I hooked it a bit on
this the the top part that's not good
I'm bringing it to you Jo there we go
another one thank you
Jock It's not a big one but it's still
the
fighter oh so
good
Freedom there he
goes on fly it's fun but lure it's fun
as well we're taking out everything
today we're doing pop qu we're doing
lures we're doing fly
fishing it's just so much
fun oh the mudfish
Mish not as big as the first one I got
but still interesting huh just look at
that mouth
oo kind of looks
alien and he's got this small head and
there bump over here but uh let's there
it go go and get
bigger oops so you're
ready there he
goes Jo now is your in yeah let's catch
you the fish are really biting Jo just
got another one as you can see another
nice yellow that he's holding tightly
it's strong yeah and uh the river just
came up we were actually there on that
island and then the river just came up
and uh we had to retreat to this little
spot over here but this is where we're
going to continue fishing jock well done
thank you fish on another one jock it
doesn't get old this is so much
fun I can just stand here and do this
the whole day Nikita is going to be so
proud catching so many fish with her
with her
rod taking
line oh no
uh mudfish mud fish why am I catching so
many mudfish so never try to touch the
fish just like this with your dry hands
it's not
good make it wet a little
bit then you touch it they have this
protective layer that's what it feels so
disgusting for a lot of people for
especially women because like you but it
actually protects them so when you um
touch it with your dry hands the fish is
not protected from disease and things so
this is what you have to
do he goes we had an amazing time here
at the Orange River but it's time to go
because the sun is beating us and we are
burning we would have liked to stay
longer but I got to head on
[Music]
home